hey y'all for real though
this right here yeah this goes out to
all our fallen homies yo
come on hey yo real tall all right
i mean
it just seems like a waste right
does that make me a dick
okay i'm a dick okay i'm a dick i'm
sorry i'm a big old
i'm okay here for our homies
come on man what's your damn beer okay
let's go all right
fine
glug glug glug glug glug glug
okay okay you need to respect our homies
okay for the homies
whoa trash beer what come on hey
beer is beer geez
i cannot win on this one what fine
i'm not on board with this but i'll do
it
hey what you doing oh really that don't
count
oh hey put that that's not oh man
it's more of a symbol than a gesture
somebody backed me up on this hey right
hey man that's disrespectful right there
you just do it
fine fine i'll pour it out i'll waste
the damn beard in
you know i'm just not a waster you know
i save everything jamal knows if you eat
a piece of pizza and don't eat the crust
i eat the crust if we do a drive-by
shooting
i will go back for the shell in case not
to hide the evidence
but because you can recycle those they
have value
man just like this beer i can't waste
nothing y'all
it's physically impossible for me to
waste this
i can't do it jamon
can you pour it out for me
oh thank you come on man i bet he's not
gonna bring him back
dude it's not gonna bring him back